hey folks welcome back to reality check
Mount Everest its peak is an astonishing
8,848 meters above sea level resulting
in an atmospheric pressure of about 1/3
of normal meaning 1/3 less oxygen to
breathe as well but as everyone knows
though it's the biggest mountain or is
it
what about Mauna Kea in Hawaii this is
actually taller than Everest at ten
thousand one hundred meters although the
majority event is under the sea
Mini's peak is only around four thousand
meters above sea level but wait what
about Olympus Mons this colossal giant
is an incredible 21,000 229 meters high
way bigger than the other two combined
surely now we have a winner although
nobody's ever climbed it because it's
actually on Mars
sometimes you see determining the
biggest thing can be a big problem so
then what is the biggest game in the
world
okay here we go time for the ground
reveal see if you can guess by the way
and the biggest game in the world is
Mario Golf World Tour did you get it
right now before you turn off the video
and send me hate messages on Twitter all
I'm saying is that you could argue that
the biggest game in the world right now
must in fact be the current best-selling
game and if we go by chart stats then
the most recent figures available those
for the week beginning the 3rd of May
2014 show that Mario Golf Tour on the
3ds comes out on top
heading sales of ninety one thousand
eight hundred and seventy three units
globally now I know that's not a very
satisfactory answer and I'm sure very
few of you would have chosen that one I
also it makes this video almost
instantly out of date so let's move
those goalposts back just a little
acknowledge the biggest game in terms of
sales so far for 2014 is EA's mech based
shooter titanfall selling roughly 1.7
million units to date but what if we
pushed that back a little further to
sales of all time
ah Tetris the relentless block building
video puzzle you could effectively argue
that this Russian export takes the
biggest game biscuit as it sold between
70 million and 143 million copies since
its initial release back in 1984 I say
between because the figures available do
seem to vary widely
either way this huge number includes
copies sold on Game Boy Game Boy Color
Nez I'm almost every mobile phone ever
bloody mate but then if you scan the
internet for other lists and blogs of
the best-selling games in the world then
games like Minecraft and Wii Sports
often topped the bill you see it's all
about how you set your parameters for
example if you go only buy more reliable
and trackable sales figures and also
include games bundled with consoles in
your codes then we sports comes out on
top at 81 million but if you say no to
bundled games on the other hand and only
can't individual copies sold
then minecraft takes a crown at just shy
of 50 million but what about entire game
franchises Mario absolutely dominates in
this case as all the Mario games ever
sold rack up a gargantuan 445 million
copies to put that number into
perspective if you counted each Mario
game sold as an individual Mario person
then the nation of Mario would in fact
be the third most populous country on
the planet behind India and China
terrifying but you know what I don't
think we should base this entirely on
money in sales it's just too messy and
and too open to interpretation than the
placement of goal posts what if instead
we base this on what people are actually
playing league of legends without that
the most popular game in the world today
and to be honest the numbers are
staggering 67 million more than the
population of France that's how many
individual people play the game every
month and it's still growing
27 million of those played daily and any
one instance say right now there could
be as many as 7.5 million of them around
the world casting spells last hitting
minions and desperately trying to land
that killing blow on an enemy champion
so do we have a winner then well maybe
bassy big could also mean
sighs Skyrim it's beautiful it's
detailed and that clocks in around 16
square miles not counting all the
delicious dungeons full of dragger words
of power and gold hidden in vases pretty
impressive but not the biggest in terms
of game world not by a long shot
Azeroth the world of World of Warcraft
is around five times that size and
approximately 80 square miles that's big
bigger than all the 3d Grand Theft Auto
worlds combined but even that is just
smashed by the elderscrolls to
Daggerfall boasting a world size of 62
thousand square miles now obviously in
terms of the quality of a game world
bigger isn't necessarily better just
compare the detail of skyrim versus
bagra for there is just no competition
but even Thakur fall doesn't take the
crown of the biggest game world
minecraft the procedurally generated
block them up has a theoretical maximum
map size on PC of 510 million and 72,000
kilometers squared but you know what
even that isn't the biggest game world
much like in real life if you want to
get into the realms of colossal size and
distance you need to take a journey into
space
Eve online the gigantic and galactic
spacefaring MMO bus and explorable
galaxy with a radius of approximately
120 light-years but that's still not the
biggest that accolade must surely go to
elite dangerous now the game is still in
production but according to creator
David Braben the galaxy ie the play
space is approximately a hundred
thousand light-years across
and contains around 400 billion star
systems basically the size of our own
Milky Way galaxy insane
now we all live our own lives can find
within our own minds our brains
construct our own reality from sensory
information and prior experience so you
could say that we all live in our own
individual worlds so then what's the
biggest game of your world mine would
have to be Skyrim as I've racked up well
over 500 hours if you combine playing at
home and messing around with Seb in top
5 Skyrim mods of the week be sure to let
me know yours though in the comments
last week on reality check I
investigated the site of inertia and
specifically how not to be turned into
mulch at the moment of blast-off to near
light speeds while perusing the comment
section on GameSpot I came across this
rather delightful conversation I have an
idea for how to withstand the bloody
backseat problem just wear a titanium
suit around your body so your bloody
pulp still remains that sexy human form
you're welcome not going to work
you'll still experience the forces only
the bloody pops that used to be your
body will be contained in titanium at
least you're surviving family will not
have to deal with the mess don't don't
forget to let me know what you thought
of this week's show either by dropping a
comment down below or by hitting me up
on Twitter oh and a little disclaimer it
is really difficult to find accurate
stats about sales and world map size and
all this kind of stuff I did my best I
did my due diligence and checked
multiple sources but if you think I've
made a grievous error do let me know in
the comments down below and I will get
back to you ok thanks for watching guys
see you next week
you